are we hoping to buy ourselves happiness
many Western Europeans and Americans
they no longer really have a firm belief
in God but you have to believe in
something
you know we have these belief systems
that reduce death anxiety but there's
always going to be a rumble of panic
beneath the surface of consciousness
we're gonna take this death anxiety and
we got to do something with it and one
thing that we can do is by oddish
in the back of our head we know that the
current Western approach to life
requires that we directly and indirectly
take advantage of other people's
war and stuff go together and they
always have our ability to consume
wanton ly requires the involuntary
subjugation of large swatches of the
rest of the world you cannot be an
American in less you can have a banana
anytime you want it or coffee anytime
want it well for that to happen I need
people to grow bananas and I need people
to grow coffee and they may like to have
something else besides banana and coffee
but we're just gonna send our military
and install our businesses there instead
the military and the leaders of the
fortune 500 companies are literally and
symbolically and ex trick oblique
connected
in the biblical story of Babel mankind
wanted to build a tower that would reach
to the heavens God punished its bride by
creating a confusion of languages the
Tower of Babel the ultimate symbol of
self-indulgence and excess when humans
aspired to be gods
of bad thanks happens our Franzi desire
for infinite amounts of stuff will have
the paradoxical consequence of being the
first form of life to be responsible for
our own extinction
it's very ominous I would argue
I wonder is mankind perhaps not an error
of evolution nature is bizarre
experiment on a small blue planet
are we really mentally incapable of
looking ahead
you